et une certaine manière l'église fait
elle aussi campagne cyprès l'un sans
jamais citer monsieur le pen où le front
national se sont mobilisés contre la
xénophobie le piège de l'idéologie
élitiste parmi eux
l'évêque d'evreux monseigneur gaillot
qui dans un article paru dans
paris-normandie écrit que le racisme
n'est pas compatible avec l'évangile
thierry paquot était aujourd'hui à
evreux il est important de dire et moi
comme évêque que le racisme n'est pas
incompatible avec l'évangile
alors vous prenez ces positions
précisément au moment de la campagne des
cantonales est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression de vous immiscer dans les
affaires politiques
je crois qu'au contraire c'est
l'événement qui commande et à cause de
cet événement j'ai pensé dire une parole
parce que la place des immigrés dans
notre pays c'est un enjeu fondamental à
côté de l'évêché une famille d'algériens
il ya une famille de portugais on essaie
d'avoir des relations de voisinage on se
rendait service
c'est pas facile de vivre ensemble quand
on est de race différente de cultures
différentes de croyances différentes et
c'est un défi qui nous est donné à tous
ou de viser personne en particulier et
je ne cherche pas viser des personnes à
condamner des personnes mais je condamne
des attitudes racistes et des idéologies
racistes qui me paraissent pernicieux ça
tout à fait jean-marie le pen s'est
sentie lui visé puis ce qui vous a
répondu par voie de presse tout à fait
alors ce fut différent le pen gaillot je
dirais que c'est pas ça qui est
important c'est c'est cet enjeu de la
place des immigrés dans le pays et
partout il ya un combat pour les droits
de l'homme je fonce il n'y a pas un
problème d'immigration en france
d'immigrés en france il ya certainement
un grave problème est dans la mesure où
il ya une crise économique et du chômage
on entend faire porter la responsabilité
aux immigrés qui vient de prendre notre
pain et ondimba les immigrés ces boucs
émissaires et donc je suis content qu'il
y en ait beaucoup aujourd'hui qu'ils
réagissent
contre le racisme et je me joins si
j'acceptais cette interview c'est pour
rejoindre tous ceux qui manifestent
contre le racisme et le tribunal